tourne faus teinte mais ça va
je recommence parce que ça va
pas c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
bon ok ve pas y aller place-toi coupe
coupe attends
doucement c'est pas souvent donc ça veut
dire qu'on normalement il pas trop nous
entend
exactement
c'est beau c'est beau on prend le temps
de regarder de profiter du
paysage un PEI là comme ça tu gardes là
comme ça elle peut
monter
mon trop moi lapin oh quoi que non
peut-être j'ai ouvert trop vite ouais
moi j' non mais c'est bon c'est bon
c'est joli c'est super joli quand même
c'est super beau ça tu mets un peu au
centre mais c'est pas mal allez on
laisse comme ça c'est beau c'est très
beau c'est très je c'est bien c'est bien
c'est bien c'est bien c'est bien c'est
bien c'est bien c'est bien c'est bien
bien voilà il bloque dans cette valeur
là
hop après ce tu peux me donner un petit
mouvement en descendant
vas-y pas peur aux animaux he ah fausse
teinte pas grave
is c'est
dus
voilàtion aux animaux on est très prês
rest
rest ils ont l'air de de
s'hituer allez
stop qu' rien pasve soleil c'est pas
grave c'est pas
grave attends attends on est
là on est là on taper
d'autres
Peet garçon il cour avec
top je juste
FA
se casser je lui dans le troupeau de
droite
euh mon cher ERC céit des chameaux
derrière c'était un peu plus beau
j'arrive le même que ça mais du FA à
droite tu vas voir c'est très beau c'est
les chameaux tu un mec ok tu vois c'est
plus
joli
le mec qui arrive derrière
vois
attends
attendsonour bouge un
peu pas
grandose ok
ok fait la même chose les chameau
derrière ça va être
sublime pas trop de sable en
l'air
non
non regarde le groupe
de ATT
pourend à gauche aussi tu un vers la
gauche tu vas voir c'est très
joli cux regarde vois comme ils sont
jolis regarde tous vers toi tendus pour
boire ils attendent l'eau regarde
to cou pas coupe pas les jambes coupe
pas les jambes
peut-être pas grave c'est pas grave
voilà voilà voilà voilà c'est top
ça
c'est beau ce plan là c'est peu ne pas
prendre le sable derrière ou pas
j'arrive j'arrive descendant un tout
petit peu c'est plus joli tois je trouve
quand tu es dedans un pe comme ça voilà
pr gardant la tête en haut voilà voà
c'est beau ça tu vois pour moi voilà je
sais pas ouais
peut-être pas si ça boue ou pas je me
rends pas compte ça bouge un petit peu
mais non non
mais ça a pas l'air de vibrer hein non
non ça vibre pas allez
coupe on est on est à 50
m c'est bien parce qu'il s'habitue il
bouge plus c'est bon la matière
là un petit
Méch
sal ce so tu vas manger
quoi mais c'est du blanc ça va passer
c'est tout blanc vous démerdez ou mais
c'est le changement qui est pas
bon mon vieuxut
assurer vaut mieux l'avoir l'un ou
l'autre mais les deux en cours de plan
c'est pas bon oh écoute tu sais c'est ça
la vie pas qu'il fasse le tour de
fr allez allez
allez a de la vie c'est vachement
il y a un truc est très beau CELI de
Dr ça se bar ça se barre j'ai
l'impression que tout le monde se barre
la fin avec son
truc ch derrière c'est
ça bien
ça Raon attention
les
éation
li pour à
gauche
ok
super
bien
g
pe pas le groupe
de
le sur la longueur vous
jamais
plus était bon de
compte
Ilous
allez va-ten
vas-y pe en aller c'est beau les chapaux
qui boivent là c'est super avec le puit
devant c'est vachement beau tu l'as bien
assuré ça le le puit devant avec les
chameaux c'est
top c'est magnifique magnifique très
beau ça très très
beau très très
beau voilà voilà voilà ça c'est très
très beau ça
une verticale qu'on a raté tout à
l'heure après quand vous aurez fini
ça
le paquet de Ch qu' a un peu le paquet
là allez on se met en vertical s'il vous
plaît vous l'z pas fait tout à
l'heure
allezour tu V pas attendre le petit coup
de soleil non c'est bon il y en a
d'ailleur AR arri
c'est bon c'est très beau ça ça c'est
beau voilà voilà beau cadre voilà un
beau
cadre le soleil se monte le soleil monte
ou le derrière ils sont à
l' il arrêé de boir j'ai l'impression ch
ils ont plus rien à
voir vas-y vas-y doucement doucement
doucement c'est il y a de l'ambiance il
y a tout c'est top
ça ge là comme ça pour
l'instant mec qui TI et tout génial
génial bien
bienad bien cadré bien cadré en plus
c'est top
ça rpre pas trop oua mais si je m'arrête
fable ah
okir que tu montes là attention attends
attends attends attends jolie ouais mais
attends c'est pas ça la c'est qu' va
faire partir tout le monde et tout notre
plan va être baisé monte allez monte
monte monte
monte doucement pas trop
vite
Gard le moi
ok on peut le refaire dans l'autre sens
en partant arrière ouais enfin tu vois
faire le même mouvement mais dans
l'autre sens ouais mais laisse tomber ok
ok c'est moi dans le vent tu VO
[Musique]
ok des
trucstir sur un autre AX mais pas le
même
coupe vasy
tranqu
c'est pas c ouais d'accord joli
bravo jeen éliminer un peu d'un d'accord
en l'ESS éliminant un
peu
un peu plus dedans non attends faisant
une valeur comme
ça peut-être
que c'est beau c'est super beau ça au
près de la dune pas trop doucement
doucement doucement pas trop TR près de
la dune pas trop vite Fran oua mais le
sable regarde derrière toi regarde je
derrière ok ok ok monter un peu ok ok là
ouais ça va c'est pas mal de loin
c'est allez termine parce sinon on peut
rien on termine comment en effaçant F
quoi
fix attends
attsuse
ok
attends
allez ça c'est pas M facile
vasy c'est joli ça très joli
ça doucement doucement descend pas
trop
il Râ tout le temps en
[Musique]
plus
est-ce que tu as fait des des gros plans
sur le mec qui R qui fait tirer l'eau
quoi sur le
luimême fait heinas fait des gros plans
sur le
PU
la pendentends le
bruit tu fais trop
bien je VO pas
estme vraimentin
le
personne
merour c'est joli
ça
est trs
lo
dérouley
est joli c'est quand la la la poulie est
tellement usée tu vois que tu as envie
d'avoir il aime pas ah il Râ tout le
temps hein non mais aim pas aussi parce
qu'on est là non non ils sont toujours
de mauvaise humeur ils aiment pas
bosser un souffle un peu derrière pour
votre info
voil ah non j'ai ok on va faire
çaù il
arrive
cour ser dedans moi je très serré dedans
quand tu fais ça
d'accord pas
raisony continue continue quand même
comme
ça al passant dans dans les ares c'est
joli ça
voilà et là on va passer vend cul donc
je obligé d'accélérer sinon ok ok vas-y
vas-y vas-y vas-y
bon
allez fais-moi un très serré làdedans
s'il te plaît
j'arrive c'est pas terrible on voit pas
bien céit mieux tout à
l'heure enc encore un
peu
c'est la phase il faut que j'accélère un
désol on
R
voilà voilà ch qui arrive le à gauche
c'est bien le à gauche
super
peut-être le à droite
maintenant va
tomber c'est pas terrible s de là
[Musique]
ire derrière
attention qu'on va
sur allez
mon
ils ont rempli des poches d'eau qu'ils
ont traîné sur le
sable
[Musique]
bien
exordire
pas que tu
faiser
pasuseuse
pas
[Musique]
coue allez ok avance un petit peu sur
les
champ bon c'est un peu c'est un peu
va les
cherchercoute garçon arrive devant il va
arriver en courant
VO ce qu'il va faire rentrer dans petit
[Musique]
garçon
op écoute on y va on y va merci
beaucoup
joli
ça joli
ça
et bientôt l'alignement avec le puit ils
vont
boire attends
attends ah c'est bon
ça audessus mais là moi je suis plein
dans le cul on on va faire sortir parce
que
c'est
bien
derrière
attends
ta
droite tu
peux c'est
j
le
B
joli
ça s de C tu crois qu'on va pouvoir le
faire de face làbas avec les dansre S
contchamp allez
vas-y vas-y coupe s'il te
plaîtoup
our oh
merde j ces plans là comme ça c'est
super beau
ça ça c'est vraiment plan que
j'aime bon écoute c'est
bon il vont plus là tu
vois
beoup
de non c'est la couleur beaucoup plus
clair coup
de
il un sacré eff de chaleur
ou pas
Frid allez mur
mer
allez on se casse coupe allez fini